vive la ville refuge de l'ukraine ici la
gare est devenu un lien vital avec le
reste du pays une plaque tournante pour
les ukrainiens qui fut la guerre ou ceux
qui choisissent de rentrer chez eux
cette famille retourne chez elle à kiev
je veux vraiment rentrer chez moi dit
victoria 18 ans je m'ennuie de ma maison
et de mon chat ou qe voisin un train
entre en gare mais ce trait ne prendra
aucun voyageur
des bénévoles de médecins sans
frontières se dépêchent des charges et
du matériel c'est que ce trait converti
en hôpital se prépare à quitter pour une
mission de trois jours il transportera
vers l'ouest des malades et des blessés
ce aménagés pour pouvoir mettre un peu
de matériel ou autre à l'entrée on a un
petit poste de santé avec plus de
matériel et sinon c'est prévu pour deux
patients à chaque fois 1-2 les
couchettes de sept anciens trains de
nuit ont été transformés en lit
d'hôpital et y en a un petit peu partout
comme ça décrocher un manteau servent à
suspendre des sacs de perfusion une
génératrice garantie l'alimentation en
électricité
la semaine dernière c'était sur le
premier voyage c'était que des blessés
donc c'était pratiquement trois familles
qui ont été pris dans les bombardements
d'évacuation de mario paul
avec des familles décimées graves et des
morts
le trait s'apprête à aller chercher une
vingtaine de patients et les ramener ici
elles vivent une façon de soulager les
hôpitaux débordés de l'est de l'ukraine
un long trajet de 24 heures qui serait
presque impossible par la route à bord
un médecin urgentiste un pédiatre un
anesthésiste et des travailleurs
humanitaires dévouées on a fait
maintenant une évacuation et si tu vois
les réactions des patients qu'on ne
ramène c'est quand même ça fait ça fait
bien au coeur quoi des moments touchants
mais aussi d'autres déchire à la semaine
dernière il ya un enfant qu'on n'a pas
pu prendre du temps choc en choc
septique et l'été trop instable pour
pouvoir être faire 24 heures de train un
autre trait sera bientôt aménagée avec
de l'équipement spécialisé pour
transporter les cas les plus graves des
patients en état critique
la destination est gardée secrète pour
des raisons de sécurité s'approcher des
zones de combat demeure risqué
je sais que ça peut être dangereux dit
cette jeune infirmière ukrainienne de 23
ans mais c'est tellement important
d'aider nos citoyens
dans un pays où le réseau ferroviaire
résiste toujours aux horreurs de la
guerre l'opération est aussi essentielle
que symbolique une locomotive imposante
et imperturbable à l'image de la
résilience des ukrainiens ici louis
blouin radio canada y vivent